hi ladies and gentlemen I'm Greg with
say the name of yours you see Howard
from six degrees of feature film yes yes
on the hit or miss movie channel yes on
YouTube and you could also catch her on
the Schmo down everyone from what we're
supposed to actually go against each
other we are going to [ __ ] some [ __ ] up
VI yeah well going down you're talking
[ __ ] I thought we were talking to the
Calabro oh oh wait I'm reversing in
genomic I'm super excited you are my
dear friend your new friend we've got to
show each other over the last few times
of behind other shows I'm so excited to
compete against you up we're gonna like
do like a group dress-up thing maybe I
don't know I'm not going to spoil
anything but you'll see you guys I like
the whole pre-interview right here yeah
cool sorry enough beating around the
bush with witty banter yeah John wick
honest trailer from serene junkie Stacey
feel like John wick I [ __ ] love John
Woo I love John wick as well ok let's
watch this ok and see if they can kind
of ruin the movie alright
you were shopping I go ever again
they stole his car they killed his job
now he's gonna kill 76 feet I can work
for the dad of the kid who did enjoy
scrap it forget it 2014 that your
friends would not shut up about the bike
the no-nonsense revenge movies of the
past
what production techniques of today in
an action flick that doesn't rely on
quick cuts or shaky cam I didn't know
you were allowed to do that
how does Liam Neeson gonna hop up in the
next a kid taking them a while that was
like 14 different meet John wig the man
makes criminals reconsider their life
choices stole John wish Cocteau Oh yawn
witness Kiana's eight and arguably best
character named John Mann tragically in
love with a video clip but after the
world was depressing cross Kings after
his wife died just steal his car and
kitties and talk he'll turn the entire
world into a game of Call of Duty and
easiest difficulty
motivate yourself a mysterious shadow
society of assassins where everyone is
way too casual about dead bodies
Sir John you are working against
complete with its own mysterious
currency cleanup crew hotel bar health
care car service and assassin jazz band
so is there like an assassin yo care
that's a deli really clear all that up a
jungle to watch as police's well what
does happen whoa what just happened
everything just win yeah technical
difficulties alright alright she's back
a tad bit we got to go back a bit okay
there's the puppy we're talking about
shafts and Dahlia does something and we
definitely want to go to poison
pepperoni go go
is there like an assassin yell assassin
daycare that's a jelly really clear all
that up and John way to watch as John
hunts down Theon Greyjoy who's gone from
literally [ __ ] to metaphorically won
another bottle go get me a bottle in
breathtaking action sequences where John
killed countless actually uh culminating
in the finale where he casually shoots
the person in confronting Ben wrestled
an old and out of sheet russian dad in
the rain gotta feel like included budget
and I could see so cool up or quad row
seat to the piano songs as this immortal
fifty year old still kicks just as much
as he did in his twenties and finally
loses the trademark shell he's been
building up since Bill and Ted as we
pray that he uh knows was off what he's
never done before
follow of a great action movie with a
sequel that doesn't suck
you have many Christians and though the
process
your consciousness you remain
irrevocably human concordantly while
your first question may be the most
pertinent you may or may not realize it
is also the most irrelevant
your life is equation head into the
program terrific story
I know gone through your friend order
for that charge
I love it Russian reek Friday Night
Lights out more headshots Oh Winston
Churchill super shredder in Ninja
Turtles - wow this wig is like 80% ha ha
ha ha ha dog ha ha ha ha jump so good at
shooting he doesn't even shoot vertical
video hey screen junkies want to hear
how Keanu Reeves really feels about John
wig I am want to kill its function I'm
not crazy
then check out our second edition of on
and on I got Irish Sea Otter est young
people behind John - to answer our dumb
questions click the Box on the left and
watch our interviews whoa there the rows
of Batman I'm shaking why was I invited
to that I kind of play boys when I say
don't you better play poison ice Orion
to the galaxy only he didn't say free
get there's that one brother I require
your hose all hail Prince is troggs
screen junkie you guys guys are so good
and my mic is so on I'm making sure I'm
sure
I remember the first time I want I
remember the first time I watched this
movie my my head kind of hurt a little
bit yeah because there was so you feel
the head shot you don't feel that and
there's also like the nightclub scene
which is the best nightclub scene since
collateral that's a good night club I'm
making playing right now there's also
like strobe lights in there I feel like
anyone that has like epilepsy can't
watch John with unfortunately I'm afraid
they can watch it like on my phone the
way you look away and it's all the
factions in the movie but then come back
to it for like the puppy walking scene
you don't like the dog like his face oh
I want a puppy really bad I want a puppy
too you know so I have two cats and if
someone killed my cat I would kill
anyone Wow it's six degrees of
separation from that person who killed
Mike I'm gonna kill one cat just so I
can silently film you and it's going to
be like a weird
arthouse film but it's like real life
this is the prelude to the next Schmoe
down Stacey killed my dog I don't wanna
beat her in this road and to prove my
work oh when I watched John wick I had
seen in Game of Thrones mm-hmm and then
I watched Game of Thrones and then I
watched John wick again I was like oh
[ __ ]
Theon Greyjoy's in this [ __ ]
character yeah he's always played like a
[ __ ] and everything huge bag son yes
that it's like daddy yeah or women cuz
he isn't he's without a dick although
you know he could get so fast by a woman
you don't know me care man got like good
fingers I don't know yeah another pnina
Tommy or whatever okay John wick - I'm
gonna go watch it tonight I got really
straight into it
yeah at the aiesec which by the way I
don't like the I pick I've been to it I
saw It's a Wonderful Life and I think oh
well that might be a different
experience I don't know I do full of
fanciness - baby it's - but John wick is
a movie that's meant to be filled with
fanciness though there's their suits
there's a hotel things and there's not
going like the Continental the
combination that all
maybe coming Constance breakfast I think
the thing about it I get the I pick
you're like laying daddy could lay down
to give you a blanket until oh let's see
and everyone's like ordering food the
whole time with her buttons and the
flashing lights and it's just it's too
phallic I want to be like invested in
the moving there's like a full nightclub
downstairs yeah it's a nightclub from I
just want to go for life I like I prefer
if it's just like reserve seating and
that's about as fancy to get room yeah
wealthy I go even cheaper and even
further I bring my own snacks but I
bring in giant purse and I come back
from the dollar store
oh my god I get be like jalapeno Lay's
chips I get some likes of the crunch bar
that's a giant ones and like a big soda
and it's like $3.00 car esis I don't
know I don't even like all I would eat
all day though oh I don't really eat
anything before that well that explains
why you are so healthy I'm very very
healthy I'm wiry you guys I got muscles
oh you okay I know I know it's a lot is
laughing how my fingers bounce off about
anyway I don't know it was really about
nothing all right what every family
super excited for it and junkies you did
it again my episode movie vs. movie of
screen junkies plus and Stacy and
Briana's episode a movie vs. movie is
going to be on screen junkies club so
let's be like this week or next week
yeah I think so I'm screen junkies what
I do I do absolutely everyone should
talk about so look at girl what is okay
I know I absolutely do everyone else
should and it's super fun and I'm sure
you guys had a great episode we had a
lot about himself and is it to puff yeah
again not as muscles not as buff as you
you cannot Alaska guys there's so much
power in these ridiculous help
size doesn't matter know what's on the
inside that can kill it does yeah she
won showed it and she
been pointed and it was it's defined my
entire friendship with Stacey okay you
got two fingers I got the fingers which
are bigger than newsChannel you can
describe it or rejects Stacey's on a hit
or miss movie six degrees of feature
film exactly
she's on a she's not a lady so Howard
this is SL our and 2012
that's our choice oh and Twitter so
Howard it's not sell our my initial
Stacy Olivia and then Howard Olivia's
your real name Olivia Simon is pretty
new healthy home thank you good job on
naming yourself thanks nice and yeah
what's your middle name Angelo Angelo oh
that's like um from tactical magic thank
you you're all but like a sympathetic Oh